on imagine la surface de la terre sur
laquelle vous êtes immobiles à une
certaine position et vous regardez le
point le plus lointain possible c'est à
dire le point de l'horizon donc
l'horizon se trouve une certaine
distance par rapport à vous qui se situe
à l'endroit où les rayons lumineux rase
le sol si bien qu'au dessus vous voyez
le ciel est en dessous vous voyez le sol
la question qu'on va se poser c'est en
imaginant que la terre est parfaitement
sphérique et donc il n'ya pas de
montagne pour bloquer votre vision ou de
creux quelle est la distance entre votre
position est la position de cet horizon
derrière lequel vous ne pouvez rien voir
à la surface de la terre donc cette
distance courbe ici
par cette distance cours on va l'appeler
h grand h pour la distance à l'horizon
et pour faire le calcul on va utiliser
plusieurs variables et notamment
l'altitude de vos yeux par rapport au
sol donc là ça peut être la hauteur de
votre corps jusqu à vos yeux si vous
êtes directement posée au sol ou si vous
êtes sur un promontoire ce serait la
hauteur du sol jusqu'à vos yeux donc
toute cette altitude cette hauteur on va
l'appeler h petit h cette fois ci et
puis on notera r le rayon de la terre
donc jusqu'à son centre
rpr et on notera une propriété
géométriques très intéressante c'est
qu'ici le rayon lumineux en provenance
de l'horizon qui parvient vos yeux et en
jean à la surface de la terre ils rasent
la surface et donc ce rayon est
perpendiculaire alors ici ça va être un
peu difficile à dessiner il faut
imaginer voilà que ce rayon est
perpendiculaire au rayon de la terre
donc ici si je résume géométriquement
cette situation on a un triangle
rectangle de cette forme là
avec ici la hauteur de vos yeux
ici le rayon de la terre ici également
le rayon de la terre et donc ici une
distance qu'on ne connaît pas c'est la
longueur de ce rayon lumineux qu'on peut
appeler l et new skies intéresse c'est
l'arc de cercle ici la longueur de cet
arc de cercle qu on notera grand h
alors le théorème de pythagore nous
permet directement de calculer la
grandeur elle ici qui est la longueur de
ce rayon lumineux le théorème de
pythagore nous dit que le carré de
l'hypoténuse donc ici l'hypoténuse ch +
r donc le carré de h+ air
est égale à la somme des carrés des deux
côtés qui sont ici air et elle
est donc en réarrangeant les termes on
peut passer le 1er quart et de l'autre
côté on obtient ici en développant
achkhar et plus de h r + r carré ça
c'est l'identité remarquable a + b au
carré - r carré en passant ce 1er quart
et de l'autre côté
est égal à elle qu'à paris si les deux
aires caressa nul et on obtient en
passant des deux côtés à la racine
carrée que la racine de achkhar et plus
de h r
est égal à elle
donc ici on a obtenu la longueur de ce
rayon lumineux en fonction du rayon de
la terre de l'altitude de vos yeux
et en première approximation cette
grandeur elle est à peu près égale à la
grandeur h donc en fait on a une
première approximation avec cette
expression ici de la distance à
l'horizon
évidemment la distance à l'horizon c'est
une distance qui est courbe c'est un arc
de cercle et donc ça n'est pas
rigoureusement égal à cette grandeur
elle en particulier si vous êtes très
haut par rapport à la surface de la
terre donc par exemple dans la station
spatiale est bien la longueur du rayon
lumineux ici est beaucoup plus grande
que la distance à l'horizon sur la terre
et donc il va falloir trouver une autre
méthode pour calculer la grandeur exact
que l'on cherche qui est cet arc de
cercle et en particulier vous savez
peut-être que la longueur d'un arc de
cercle peut être déterminé à partir de
l'angle ici que forment cet arc de
cercle et du rayon de cet arc de cercle
donc si on appelle et à cet angle notre
but ça va être de trouver l'angle d'état
et à partir de là on pourra exprimer que
la distance à l'horizon h c'est à dire
la longueur de l'arc de cercle est égale
simplement aux rayons x l'angle de l'arc
de cercle
alors ceci c'est une formule qu'il faut
connaître et en particulier site et à
égal 2 pis on se retrouve avec un cercle
complet et on retrouve bien la formule
que le périmètre d'un cercle est égale à
deux pierres
alors quelle est la valeur de cet angle
d'état
ici l'état on ne peut pas vraiment le
déterminer directement mais on peut le
déterminer en utilisant des formules de
trigonométrie on a vu qu'on a un
triangle rectangle et on connaît les
côtés de ce triangle et donc on peut
déterminer le sinus le cosinus ou la
tangente de l'angleterre a
alors ici c'est comme vous le souhaitez
on pourra exprimer le sinus ou le
cosinus ou la tangente de teta et en
déduire une expression pour h dans
d'autres cas comme on a déjà calculé
elle ici on va pouvoir exprimer la
tangente dette et à tangente deux états
c'est égal au côté opposé donc le côté
opposé at état et si c'est elle
sur le côté adjacent ici c r
on pourrait également exprimé le sinus
comme étant l / h + r ou le cosinus
comme étant air / h + r et à partir de
ça on peut inverser l'expression c'est à
dire appliquer des deux côtés de
l'équation une fonction qui est l'arc
tangente c'est la fonction réciproque de
la fonction tangente donc on peut
l'appliquer des deux côtés on la note
comme ça dan - ou à leur arc tan
de tangente état est égal à thann - un
arc tan de l / r
et ici du fait que thann - et la
fonction réciproque de la tangente les
deux salles hull et on obtient teta
égale arc tangente de l sur air et si on
peut utiliser l'expression qu'on avait
obtenu pour elle c'est à dire racine
carrée de achkhar et plus de hr
sur air
donc pour terminer la distance à
l'horizon grand h est égale simplement
au rayon
grand air
x cet arc tangente ici
et
cette expression c'est l'une des
expressions possible pour obtenir la
distance à l'horizon à la surface de la
terre en fonction de l'altitude de vos
yeux alors ici pourquoi j'ai pris cette
expression là j'aurais pu prendre le
sinus et donc on aurait obtenu quelque
chose de la forme arc sinus de l / h + r
alors là aussi on aurait eu une racine
carrée un peu complexe avec l'expression
de l mais j'aurais pu prendre l'arc
caussinus de r / h + r
là on aurait eu besoin d'aucune racine
carrée ou d'aucune autre expression donc
en particulier on n'aurait pas eu besoin
de déterminer la grandeur elle j'ai
décidé d'utiliser cette version ici avec
l'arc tangente car lorsque vos yeux sont
très proches du sol par rapport au rayon
de la terre l'argument ici à l'intérieur
de l'acte en jantes est très petit une
propriété de l'arc tangente c'est que
pour des très petites valeurs arc
tangente est à peu près égale à son
argument donc c'est un peu comme si on
pouvait supprimer la fonction ici arc
tangente les airs et si ça nul et on
retrouve bien que dans l'approximation
ou vos yeux sont très proches du sol la
distance à l'horizon est à peu près
égale à elle